BE PICTURED KNEELING BEFORE
DISTANT MONARCH HAPPENED FOR THE
QUEEN'S DIAMOND JUBILEE IN 2012.
A POLL BY U GOF DOWN AT THE TIME
OF THE PLATINUM JUBILEE JUST
THIS LAST MAY FOUND THAT 62% OF
BRITAINS SAID THEIR COUNTRY
SHOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE A
MONARCHY IN THE FUTURE.
WITH ONLY 22% SAYING IT SHOULD
INSTEAD MOVE TO HAVING AN
ELECTED HEAD OF STATE.
BUT THERE'S A STARK GENERATIONAL
DIVIDE ASKED IF THE MONARCHY IS,
QUOTE, GOOD FOR BRITAIN, 74% OF
THOSE 65 AND UP SAY YES.
67% OF THOSE 50 TO 64.
BUT AGES 25 TO 49, THE NUMBER
DROPS TO 49.
AND AMONG THE 18 TO
24-YEAR-OLDS, IT'S JUST 24%.
TODAY'S FRONT PAGE OF THE NEW
YORK TIMES HAS THIS HEADLINE IN
LONDON, MOURNING FOR QUEEN
EXPOSES A GENERATIONAL DIVIDE.
SUPPORT FOR MONARCHY FADES AMONG
THE YOUTH.
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT
POST-ELIZABETH THE AFFECTION FOR
THE WHOLE SYSTEM MAY SPLINTER.
SOME OF THAT MAY JUST BE
YOUTHFUL HOSTILITY THAT COULD
SOFTEN OVER TIME.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN ENGLAND'S
NEW PRIME MINISTER HERSELF BACK
IN 1994 LIZ TRUSS GAVE A FIERY
SPEECH CALLING FOR THE END OF
THE MONARCHY.
>> WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE BORN TO RULE.
OR THAT THEY SHOULD PUT UP AND
SHUT UP ABOUT DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR EVERYDAY LIVES.
WE MET ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE
AND ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE AND
ALL THREE GROUPS OF PEOPLE SAID
ABOLISH THE MONARCHY.
IN FACT, CONFERENCE, WE COULDN'T
FIND A SINGLE MONARCHIST OUTSIDE
THE ROYAL PAVILION.
HOW IRONIC.
>> NOW, OF COURSE, IN HER NEW
POSITION OF POWER, TRUSS ENDED
HER PUBL